My collagen powder has methylated multivitamins.
Should I discontinue?
So I presume this is a collagen powder
that you're using that you chose to purchase separately.
That's not something I recommended.
If it has methylated supplements in it,
I would say to discontinue using it.
And again, I have some blog posts on why cancer patients
shouldn't be generally taking methylated supplements.
And of course, the exception to that rule
is if a person has elevated homocysteine,
then we need to use folate
and maybe methylcopolamine to help reduce homocysteine levels.
But if you don't have elevated homocysteine
and you have a diagnosis of cancer,
you shouldn't be taking methylated vitamins.
Even if your family members
that don't have a diagnosis of cancer,
can they take methylated multivitamins?
Well yes and no, you just have to be careful
as anybody has to be careful
taking too much methylated supplements
because they probably haven't had their genetic profile done.
And if they have defects in different pathways,
the excess methylated supplements
can push different pathways
and can cause other issues.
So if a person doesn't have cancer,
or if they do have cancer,
and they have defects in their biopterate pathway,
it can push that pathway,
and cause some mood issues,
some anger issues, rage issues,
uncontrolled behavior.
And you see this quite frequently.
I would be careful taking excess methylated supplements from
is when the supplement companies found out
about the MTHFR defect,
this is about 10, 15 years ago,
all the companies started adding methyl tetrahydrofolate,
methylcobolamine to many of their different supplements.
So that if you're taking multiple supplements,
you could be getting methylated folate,
methylated cobalamine in multiple supplements.
And many times it's far exceeding the recommended daily allowance.
So you're getting way too much methylated supplements.
But as a cancer patient,
you have to be even more diligent to read your labels
and to be careful on excess methylation
because that turns off tumor suppressor genes.
And one could even make an argument,
maybe no one in the world is making this argument by me.
But the high use of methylated supplements
could actually be contributed to the increase cancer
phenomena that we're seeing today.
That's at least a piece, just one little piece.
So even natural people,
wow, how did I get cancer?
I've been taking supplements and doing things naturally
and eating organic for so long.
And now I have this cancer.
Look at your supplements.
You've been taking methylated supplements.
For the last 10 years,
thinking that you're doing good for yourself
and yet you are actually increasing your risk for cancer
because you're turning off tumor suppressor genes.
Just like if a person has a lot of tumor suppressor gene defects,
you're basically silencing it by taking excess methyl groups.
Just in my two cents.